all things trade are on the agenda at
the apec summit today with u.s president
joe biden and chinese leader xi jinping
both addressing leaders of the pacific
rim
the meeting is being hosted by new
zealand it's held entirely as a virtual
event apec members focused mostly on the
slow recovery from the covet 19 pandemic
for the first days in an earlier address
to the group leaders
mr xi warned that the region must not
return to the tensions of the cold war
era
the comment was seen as a reference to
efforts by the united states to blunt
what they see as china's growing
economic
and military influence
we'll look further into the expectations
of the apex summit in a second here
first let's take a quick look at the 21
members of the asia pacific economic
cooperation the group represents nearly
3 billion people and 60 percent of the
world's gdp and includes some of the
world's largest economies like the
united states japan
or china
all right let's talk more about what's
at stake at the apec meeting with alicia
garcia herrera asia pacific chief
economist at nexus
natixis investment bank good to have you
on the program um alicia what do you
expect from this meeting against the
backdrop of cop 26 which enters its
final day today
well this is an important meeting
because there's a number of issues that
we've not fully understood
in
you know as we were heading to the end
of cop 26 in particular china's real
commitment to reduce
coal in the production of electricity
and more generally in its energy basket
there's been a quote-unquote an
agreement with the u.s to do so but at
the same time china has forcefully
uh announced that it will continue its
own path and rather than commit to
multilateral or bilateral so that has to
be clarified i would argue
so when china's state and party leader
ji jinping says that asia pacific
nations should make the post-pandemic
recovery a green one how much do you
trust these words then
well i mean everybody has to reduce
emissions and i think it's it's it's
positive for hear that but it's not
enough not to finance call um outside of
china which is what xi jinping has
committed so far but rather stop
basically producing cold and consuming
coal in china or at least reduce it
obviously so in other words i think the
best uh way to believe these words is to
hear what he has to say about his own
commitment i.e china's reduction by by
all means china is the largest consumer
of of coal uh followed by india and
indonesia so china has to lead the way
here let alone the u.s by the way
obviously the u.s needs to you mentioned
the big two players here i was going to
get to here in a second there's the
growing competition between the united
states and china of course um
tensions have been building over taiwan
human rights and trade
are there any easings of these tensions
in sight according to you
yes but it's not a real easing i would
call it the risking i think the us is
very keen to the risk
the situation and the reason is not
trade
it might be climate but the most
important reason is taiwan by all means
and purposes because uh we're very close
to
either a conflict or a mistake leading
to a conflict and therefore i think the
u.s is keen to risk the relation with
china and that's what why we have all of
these meetings lately yeah
and speaking of taiwan taiwan and china
both have applied to join a pacific rim
trade pact the comprehensive and
progressive agreement for trans-pacific
partnership how is this going to play
out
well taiwan tried when this was still an
obama initiative
uh ttp and he didn't manage it's just
politically very difficult but it was
very difficult for the us then which
probably was in a stronger position
to let taiwan in so i think it's a loss
cause it's going to be very difficult
but to make it even harder china
probably this is my reading accelerated
its own uh application
right before taiwan if you saw the
timing like two days before taiwan so
it's kind of closing the door right
there so uh it's going to be very hard
for taiwan unfortunately not not a
chance in my opinion
alicia garcia herrera asia pacific chief
economist at natexis thank you for your
thoughts
thank you